on International women's day we're
celebrating some of the amazing women
who've inspired Us by achieving
greatness lifting up others and being
the Catalyst for change these are their
stories
[Music]
foreign
an ancient South Indian martial art
[Music]
the art of Clary is practiced with the
use of one's bare hands sticks
and heavy swords and shields
everybody
[Music]
foreign
s to be dirty our fingers to be dirty we
are together and we are fixing cars
around the world
foreign
make sure you do your you have your
homework done I need to see the papers
all right then good luck my name is
Sandra aguerbo I'm the first female
mechanic in Nigeria and the founder of
the lady mechanic initiative I've been a
mechanic for 32 years and I've been
running my own garage for 22 years now
so that is the way it works the leading
mechanic initiative is working with the
vulnerable group
they has commercial sex workers the
school dropouts married women wants to
acquire skill they are like there's no
more hope in my life I said to them you
know what you have got a lot of hope I'm
going to help you build that hope I mean
I here she has five children and she's a
mechanic amazing
because they are vulnerables they don't
have money they are from poor background
so they don't pay to learn and we do all
this from the founders funders pay their
stipends pay for their lecture overall
and my training is just free of charge
you want to be able to help other women
as well now we've been able to empower
graduated by thousand female mechanics
in Nigeria in five states
I mean the first female mechanic in
Nigeria is not a Bed of Roses may have
been there from generation to generation
fixing cars when I came in it was like
excuse me are you okay or you need to
see a doctor but no I knew what I was
doing but for me to become the first
female mechanic in Nigeria I had to work
five times harder than the way the men
would work
prove myself many people they don't know
me by my name is Lady mechanic
everywhere I go now a lot of guests
wants to come to Nigeria to learn how to
discuss
it's the best job in the world for any
woman I say
foreign
80 years of age
[Music]
I bench press
110 pounds
I started training at age 71.
I was named the oldest female
competitive bodybuilder at the Guinness
Book of World Records
my sister and I started exercising
together
I had never done any type of exercising
before
she died she said promise me you will
follow my dream and try to get in the
Guinness Book of World Records
so that's what I did
I have been in six or seven competitions
I win but some I come out second and
third and I'm pleased with that
I'm up every morning at 2 30. after I
have my devotions I walk and I run
approximately 10 miles I'm at the gym at
7 30 and I have a group of ladies that I
train damn
why I train all ages one of the youngest
I think she's about 20 years of age and
the rest go from 40 all the way up to
80.
foreign
[Music]
for the very first time they are really
really surprised
they said I didn't think this exercise
would be this tough but if you can do it
we are going to do it too
[Music]
I really don't feel as though I'm 80
years of age but I am
I want to keep training until
my day is done
[Music]
chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around you the dry ice
is taking the thermal energy from the
water and unfortunately I
instantaneously get judged on my
appearance that is very frustrating for
me so I'm gonna pick up my hot water I'm
gonna come over here and I'm going to
throw it right into my bucket okay it
means I have to work harder but at the
end it is so so incredibly worth it and
one
[Music]
my name is Dr Kate beberdorf and I'm a
lecturer at the University of Texas at
Austin
I'm trying to break the stigma of what a
stereotypical scientist looks like so my
thing is I am not wearing a bow tie I'm
not wearing suspenders I don't have some
frumpy cardigan on I'm just some regular
girl who likes to play with fire and I
also really like designer shoes and
that's okay as the alginate hits the
calcium chloride the alginate would
prefer to be with the two plus charge
calcium instead of the one plus charge
sodium and what happens
is we Farm gummy worms doesn't matter
what you look like any human can be a
scientist
I definitely try to use energy and
excitement I love this one I do my best
to try to reach students that might be
intimidated by science I use anything
that will make the 483 students sit up
straight and actually listen to the
words coming out of your mouth
as soon as I've exploded something in
their face I have their attention for
just 60 seconds and I can do whatever I
can to shove that knowledge right into
their brains
foreign
okay so what we're going to do today is
doing some chemistry we're gonna do
three different Hands-On experiments I
find chemistry to be an incredibly
challenging topic pour your water pour
your water beautiful now keep watching
keep watching I'm so sick of the
stereotypical female scientists and we
can do things other than biology by the
way chemistry physics engineering we can
do it look at what you made the fact
that I've been able to master it but
then use science to start the
conversation but then physically stand
there and break that image it's the most
rewarding thing I could ever do ever
right after school I just like try to
like run to the gym so I can climb
it's a dangerous sport but the only
thing that I'm afraid of is not being
able to get to the topic
with climbing I don't think that it
really matters with how big you are if
you're a smaller you can hold on longer
and your hands might be smaller so it
can fit more fingers on hold
foreign
I started climbing in Central Park when
I was six years old now I don't think I
can like live without it
when you're close to the top of the
climb you're trying to do you have
forums usually feel like they're going
to explode and they're gonna like burst
open and you feel like you have to let
go but with climbing you just can't let
go
I think that climbing is it's obviously
a sport but it's also like a dance you
sort of have to be able to like flow up
the wall and come up with their own
technique to get to the topic
I think people are shocked if I do
something that they can't do is
something because I'm still really young
and I'm a girl so like doing something
that even if a guy can't do is pretty
special
[Music]
foreign